y vamos a resolver el problema 33 que
dicen encuentran una recta que sea
paralela a la siguiente recta y igual a
menos cinco cuartos de equis más dos y
bueno dos rectas son paralelas si tienen
la misma pendiente y en este caso que
tenemos una recta en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen la pendiente es el
coeficiente que está al lado de x es
decir que mi pendiente es igual a menos
cinco cuartos por lo tanto tengo que
encontrar una recta que tenga una
pendiente de al menos cinco cuartos y
como tendría la misma pendiente entonces
serían paralelas bueno en mis sencillos
el inciso dice que es igual a menos
cinco cuartos de x más uno y por lo
tanto esta es mi respuesta porque ya
tenemos la misma pendiente lo único
distinto es que corta al eje de las diez
en un punto distinto por lo tanto la
respuesta es el inciso a y ahora vamos a
hacer el problema 34 así que mejor
déjame copiarlo y pegarlo por aquí y
entonces aquí está
perfecto cual es la gráfica que
representa la solución desde el sistema
de desigualdades y tengo estas dos
desigualdades así que tengo cuatro
gráficas y yo le pidió saber es cuál es
la gráfica que representa este sistema
de desigualdades y bueno no queda de
otra vamos a tomar la primera
desigualdad y vamos a empezar a trabajar
con ella a ver qué nos queda entonces
tengo 2 x esto es mayor o igual que
menos 1 y ahora si yo quiero despejar
ayer de aquí lo que voy a hacer es sumar
uno de ambos lados de la desigualdad y
me queda que 2x más uno es mayor o igual
que james y bueno esto es exactamente lo
mismo y lo voy a poner un poco más
ordenado que james es menor o igual que
2 x más 1 qué quiere decir esto que si
nosotros nos fijamos en la recta que
corta el eje de las 10 en 1 y que tiene
una pendiente de 2 entonces queremos
todas las guías que sean menor o igual
que esta recta esta recta corta en el
eje leyes en 1 y tiene una pendiente de
dos porque si caminamos dos a la derecha
subimos cuatro entonces ésta puede ser
un candidato de nuestra recta sin
embargo estamos
el conjunto de solución que sea más
chico que eso por lo tanto esta no puede
ser esta de aquí si funciona porque
tenemos una pendiente igualados cortamos
en yeguada 1 pero lo mejor de todo esto
es que la parte sombreada es menor que
esta recta que es justo lo que querían
estas nos sirve porque la parte
sombreada es mayor que esta recta y por
lo tanto yo lo que quiero es que sea
menor que esta recta aquí no sé tomando
10 mayores si te das cuenta cualquier
punto de esta parte sombreada cumple que
es menor que esta recta que una recta ye
igual a 2 x + 1 entonces ésta podría
funcionar pero espera tenemos otras dos
gráficas estas dos de trabajo y si te
das cuenta tenemos la misma recta el
único problema y la única diferencia es
que aquí tenemos a todas las 10 que sean
menores que esa recta mientras que en el
otro lado tenemos a todas las guías que
sean mayores que esa recta fíjate bien
cómo que quedamos la parte de abajo de
esta recta y en este inciso d también
estamos en la parte de abajo de esta
recta aquí el ejercicio d
bien puede ser nuestra solución entonces
como no sabemos si es el inciso se puede
fijémonos en nuestra siguiente
desigualdad o no tenemos un problema no
tenemos desigualdad qué raros de esto
déjame ver qué dice el problema hoy ya
ya el problema dice que nuestra
respuesta es el inciso c por lo tanto un
error tipográfico un error de dedo aquí
no pusieron desigualdad vamos a ver qué
es igualdad tendremos que tener para que
nos dé respuesta el inciso c guau este
problema creo que ya está quedando mejor
fíjate bien en esta recta yo lo que
quiero es que esta de aquí ahora en lo
que me voy a fijar es en esta cosa que
tenemos aquí quiero saber si esto es
mayor o igual menor o igual o igual o
qué pasa con esto entonces ahora la
pregunta se cambió ya sabemos que la
mejor gráfica o la gráfica que es la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
es la cem vamos a ver qué símbolo
necesitamos aquí para que nuestra
respuesta correcta sea la cem entonces
aquí en este circuito es justo lo que
estoy buscando aún mayor o igual o un
menor o igual y para esto lo puede hacer
primero es sumar 5 de ambos
la ecuación para poco a poco ir
despejando allí así que que me va a
quedar si yo somos cinco llega ambos
lados de la ecuación desigualdad no sé
qué sea esto entonces lo quedarían 2x
circulito recuerda que este circuito es
precisamente lo que quiero saber si es
mayor o igual o menor o igual 10 5 y
ahora lo que voy a hacer es pasar este
10 del otro lado de la cosa con el signo
contrario me quedaría 2x - james
circulito es igual a 5 y recuerda que
este circuito es lo que no sabemos que
por cierto no puede ser un signo de
igual porque tenemos una región entonces
o es mayor o igual o es menor o igual o
no te queda de otra
entonces para esto es es dividir todo
entre 5 me queda 2x entre 5 menos 2
es algo de jeff y ya que ya tengo
despejada game y por lo tanto lo que
quiero es la región que sea que bueno lo
que quiero buscar en este circuito es
una región que sea más grande que esta
ecuación si te das cuenta quedamos
arriba de esta recta me dicen que mi
conjunto solución tiene que estar abajo
de esta desigualdad que tengo de morado
pero a su vez tiene que estar arriba de
esta recta y por lo tanto si quiero que
esté arriba de esta recta entonces aquí
tengo que poner mayor que nada no nada
más pero espera no mayor que porque los
gráficos en la gent por lo tanto la y
que tiene que ser más grande que esta
expresión que tengo aquí es decir que
para que la respuesta en el problema sea
en el cis o sea yo tengo que tener aquí
el símbolo de menor que para que mis
respuestas enlace 2 x menos 5 y tiene
que ser menor que 10 o dicho de otra
manera dos quintos de x menos 2 tiene
que ser menor que y justo con esto
entramos a la región del inciso c y date
cuenta que esta región no funciona
porque aquí pasa justamente lo contrario
estamos arriba de la recta que no quería
mostrar arriba queríamos dar abajo y del
otro lado estamos abajo es la recta que
queremos estar arriba por lo tanto esta
es la región opuesta en fin vamos a
resolver otro problema de este examen
mejor déjenme borrar todo esto pasando
por acá y vamos a hacer otro problema
espero que este problema sí tenga
solución o al menos no tengamos que
modificar perfecto aquí está cuál es la
solución del sistema de ecuaciones y
aquí tengo dos ecuaciones un sistema de
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y
tengo cuatro incisos ahora bien para
encontrar la solución del sistema de
ecuaciones lo que voy a hacer de esta
ecuación de aquí arriba es pasarla de la
siguiente manera voy a sumar 3 x de
ambos lados de la ecuación de tal manera
que me queda 3x más bien esto es igual a
menos 2 no te asustes lo único que hice
fue sumar 3 dejan poner el contro color
3x de ambos lados de la ecuación y si
sumó 13 quitamos la ecuación estos dos
se cancelan y bueno llegó a esta
ecuación de aquí y hoy ya te diste
cuenta lo que quiero enseñarte es que
estamos hablando de la misma recta dos
veces si esta recta de aquí arriba la
multiplicó por dos de ambos lados de la
ecuación aquí llego fíjate bien que voy
a llegar a la misma expresión de la
ecuación de aquí abajo entonces voy a
multiplicar por 2 esta parte y me queda
2 x 3 x es 6 x
2 porque me quedan 2 james y esto es
igual voy a multiplicar por 2 también el
otro lado de la ecuación a menos 2 por 2
lo cual es menos 4 y qué creés son
exactamente iguales esta recta y la
recta que acabo de encontrar esta de
aquí por lo tanto estamos hablando de la
misma recta y cuando yo quiero encontrar
la solución del sistema de ecuaciones
estoy buscando en donde se intersectan
pero si son la misma recta entonces se
intersectan en cada uno de sus puntos
porque son la misma recta es decir
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones
porque todos sus puntos son solución de
este sistema así que vamos a hacer otro
problema más
ya tengo aquí un espacio y voy a copiar
y pegar el siguiente problema que es
éste declinó este o no espera esté aquí
tengo este par de ecuaciones y yo lo que
quiero encontrar es la solución de este
sistema de ecuaciones y para esto creo
que lo mejor es hacer el método de suma
y resta lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar la ecuación de abajo por
menos 1 de tal manera que la ecuación
arriba me queda x + 3 y igual a 7 a esto
no dice nada ya la de abajo le voy a
cambiar
el signo es decir lo voy a multiplicar
por menos 1 y que me quedan menos por x
me queda menos x menos por dos y me
queda menos 2 y menos por 10 me queda
menos 10 y ahora sí si sumo este par de
ecuaciones ya voy a encontrar la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
de una manera muy sencilla fíjate bien
vamos a utilizar el método de suma y
resta y vamos a sumar estas dos
ecuaciones de tal manera que la x se va
a cancelar entonces estos dos se
cancelan x menos x se cancelan y después
no queda 3 y 2 james es lo mismo que
james del otro lado tengo 7 menos 10 710
es lo mismo que menos 3 o 3 negativo si
si si tengo 7 pesos pero debo 10 pues
entonces terminó debiendo 3 pesos
perfecto ya tengo el valor de james
ahora lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el
valor de y en la ecuación de arriba para
encontrar el valor de x entonces me
quedan x + 3 proyecto pero lleva al
menos 3
entonces me quedarían x + 3 x menos 3 es
igual a 7 y si de aquí multiplico 3 x
menos 3 me quedan menos 9 esto es igual
a 7 y ahora sumando 9 vemos lados de la
ecuación queda que x
a 79 lo cuales 16 ya tengo el punto de
intersección de estas dos rectas de esos
puntos 16 como menos 3 o cuando x 3 16
lleva al de igual a menos 3 y aquí tengo
la solución así que vamos a hacer el
último problema de este vídeo y el
último problema que es este problema de
clic y dice así marta colección en
monedas de 10 centavos y de 25 centavos
y en total tiene 100 monedas si la suma
del dinero de todas sus monedas es de 14
pesos con cinco centavos cuántas monedas
de veinticinco centavos tienen así que
vamos a escribir las ecuaciones que
resuelven este sistema de mascún es
decir la cantidad de monedas de 10
centavos más la cantidad de monedas de
veinticinco centavos tienes que ser
igual a 100 porque tenemos 100 monedas y
por otra parte lo que valen las maneras
de disfrutar
es decir punto 10 de peso por la
cantidad de monedas de 10 centavos más
punto 25 por la cantidad de monedas de
25 centavos esto tiene que ser igual a
la cantidad de dinero que tenemos en
pesos 14.05 pesos y perfecto ya con eso
tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones con 250
y con dos ecuaciones
utilizando los dos datos que me da el
problema y yo quiero saber cuántas
monedas de veinticinco centavos tengo
así que para esto y para resolver este
sistema de ecuaciones voy a aplicar el
método de suma y resta y lo que voy a
hacer es de esta ecuación de acá arriba
a este cuestión de carrivale voy a
multiplicar por menos punto uno o por
menos punto 10 para que se cancele con
este punto 10 que tenemos aquí abajo
entonces vamos a multiplicarlo por menos
punto 1 y me queda menos punto uno de
menos punto uno de menos punto 10 de es
lo mismo menos más por menos es menos
menos punto de scu esto es igual a 100
por menos punto uno suele que recorrer
el punto y me va a quedar menos 10 menos
10 es decir estamos dividiendo al cien
en diez pedacitos y me queda menos 10
aquí y ahora voy a sumar estas dos
ecuaciones y vamos a ver que me quedan
estos dos puntos 10 de menos puntos de
éste se van se cancelan eso es lo que yo
quería por otra parte tengo más punto
25.10 q pues estos punto 15
hasta aquí vamos bien y eso tiene que
ser igual a 14.05 menos 10
14.05 10 es lo mismo que 4.05 y aquí
vamos bastante bien ya que acabamos el
problema porque hay que dividir todo
entre punto 15 para encontrar la
respuesta pero como no me gusta el punto
decimal voy a multiplicar todo por 100
de una vez y me queda que lincecum es
igual a 405 esto es lo mismo y después
ahora voy a dividir todo entre 15
entonces me queda que es igual a 405
entre 15 que cuánto es quien se acabe
dos veces en 42 por 15 30 y 40 menos 30
va a ser 10 entonces que me queda 10
bajó el 5 y 15 cuentas les caben 105
pues es 30 60 91 7 perfecto 7 veces 7
por 15 curiosamente 105 y entonces esto
me da exacto y ya tengo la respuesta que
es igual a 27 es decir la cantidad de
monedas que tengo es de 25 centavos es